this morning former first lady barbara
Bush is being remembered as a fiercely
loyal wife and mother and a leading
public servant in her own right the wife
of President George Herbert Walker Bush
and the mother of president george w
bush was 92 when she died at home
yesterday a family spokesman said on
sunday that mrs. Bush wasn't failing
health receiving only comfort care
she had battled congestive heart failure
and chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease
mark Strassmann is outside the gated
community in Houston where Barbara Bush
lived with her husband mark good morning
good morning from a somber City we're
standing outside the Bush families gated
community here in Houston where the
former first lady battled a number of
health issues over the years including a
thyroid condition and heart and lung
challenges but right to the end her
family says she was alert she was chatty
and she was even enjoying her favorite
bourbon here's the thing she had great
faith she truly believes that she is
there's an afterlife that she'll be
wonderfully received in the arms of a
loving God and therefore did not fear
death and as a result of her soul being
comforted on the deathbed my soul is
comforted Barbara Bush died Tuesday
evening surrounded by family and friends
former President George HW Bush her
husband of 73 years held her hand
throughout the day mrs. Bush's body left
her family home for the last time in a
motorcade later that night a family
spokesman said her husband is
brokenhearted but lifted up by his large
and supportive family and is determined
to be there for them the entire country
especially the city of Houston Texas is
gonna be grieving for a long time
because she was such a presence neighbor
Lindy Niehaus has been friends with
Barbara Bush for decades she had a
wonderful sense of humor she was such a
lating just the ultimate lady
she just was so kind and compassionate I
always think if the the world could be
full of Barbara Bush's the world would
be a much better place mrs. Bush will be
buried at Texas A&M on the grounds of
the George Bush Presidential Library
next to her daughter Robin who died when
she was a little girl the funeral
service by invitation only will be at
the bush family's Episcopal Church here
in Houston on Saturday and the general
public can pay his respects at the same
church on Friday thank you so much mark